I've been thinking a lot and it's not
just not just me but my my good friend
and Associate Jim Pitt who's been
working with me since the beginning we
started with me in 93 working on
um what kind of music we wanted to
explore and what we wanted the
philosophy our philosophy to be uh of of
putting new stuff out there and Taking
Chances and we were talking a lot about
your work and one of the things that was
coming to mind so much is there's a lot
of Yearning a lot of looking back in
your work
from the very beginning and it's been a
theme of
getting back to some place getting to
something that evokes strong feelings
for you whether it's a place that you
you know in in helpless whether it's
uh whether it's a a time in your life
it feels like it's a theme you've been
working through so we have the notion
that maybe would ask you if you go back
to your youth are there a couple of
songs
that spoke to you that were evocative of
something and you gave us a couple yeah
I gave you a few there yeah and if
you're if you're cool with it I'd love
to play them right now we'll take you
down we should play them memory uh Lane
the first one I don't know if you we
could talk afterwards and maybe you want
to talk before the first one is Four
Strong wins by Ian and Sylvia
do you remember where you were when you
heard this song for the first time or no
but I loved it so much that I would you
know put nickels and dimes in the
Jukebox to play it over and over and
over again until I didn't have any
change I just stand there in front of it
and listen to it it was a beautiful song
for some reason it really really got to
me all right unless I could feel the
magic of the music let's take you back
uh you're you're a kid at this point
when you're hearing this song uh I guess
I'm probably
11 11. okay there's an 11. something
like that maybe a little older I'm not
sure but I would say you're 12. I'm just
gonna throw that out there because we're
gonna pick a date and you're 12 years
old and where are you living in Winnipeg
you're living in Winnipeg and I was uh I
heard the song before but I uh uh I was
at Falcon Lake a place that's near
Winnipeg it's a kind of a just a lake
with uh you can pitch tents around it
sure so we had our tent to my friend
Jack and I who played drums in the
squires my first band and we were if we
were out there and I would find I found
this thing on the jukebox in the
restaurant let's give it a list just
plated that's a beautiful song that's
quite a song yeah would it uh that's not
the original version that I heard them
do though because that's stereo right
okay that was mono when I was listening
to it
mix and a jukebox yeah so it's more
jangly guitars and uh what do you think
uh when you hear it now does it take you
right back there eventually it at first
it Disturbed me a little because it was
stereo and it wasn't where I had gone in
my head when I was talking about it so I
but because I have a a memory of it
that's so strong but the music is there
and it's uh it's that's it's it got
there and I can hear her singing and him
singing and the whole thing I'm still uh
uh uh it seems
a
little
I don't know if this is the version they
may have even re-recorded it for stereo
because they may have sang it all on One
mic and done everything together in mono
the first time
so uh when that the song came out and
you heard and it's a popular song and
it's a hit and it was great and he's
saying I'm going to Alberta was there
some part of you that was like this
this
well they see this resonates he's
talking about where I'm from he's
talking about my country uh and this is
a hit on the radio that must have been
powerful it was great um you know it's
nice to hear one of the other provinces
uh you know could easily have been
Manitoba or Saskatchewan nothing rhymes
with Manitoba or Saskatchewan I know
Alberta wins again no wait Saskatchewan
moving on we got that yeah
um so you know
foreign